bonsoir dave perkins persie d'être avec
nous donald trump 1 qui se fait de plus
en plus présent médiatiquement il
profite de la mauvaise passe de joe
biden pour revenir sur le devant de la
scène selon vous
umicore tire qui ont trait sur ses
rivaux ce pas trop forcer news lorsqu'il
sera prêt et je pense d'après les signes
qu'il est prêt à repartir encore pas
gagné et que les choses vont bien se
passer pour plus de réseau par joe biden
effectivement un pool en décor à bleus
dans de nombreux domaines qu'il s'agisse
de prix des matériaux noté carburant la
devise laisse
l'armée américaine ont commencé
effectivement cela tam est en train de
profiter de sa popularité auprès de ses
partisans et sa popularité n'a pas
baissé au cours des mois
précédents donc c'est certain tous les
trains de ce rang campagne pour les
sélections
il a eu de très bons résultats
économiques
il aa baissé les impôts il a va forcer
l'emploi pour
renforcer le mans n'a rien de neuf on a
eu des résultats exceptionnels en tant
que président sauf bien sûr s'il s'agit
des relations avec les médias car ils
n'étaient pas prêts aux nivéaux
d'obligations auxquels sera confronté
dans ma mémoire est bonne cette fois ci
je pense qu'il a tout à fait prêt
qu'il a eu le temps de préparer le plan
hockey je pense que nous la campagne de
connaître un peu contraire joe biden en
échec aura beaucoup plus de succès que
ce qui s'est passé en 2009
la première on l'entend au mieux est-ce
que tout le parc est parti républicain
suivra comme un seul homme un donald
trump
candidats à nouveau selon vous
républicain est divisée comme il l'était
déjà avant que donald trump remporte ses
premières élections
mais la croissance ne sont pas et de
soutien ce succès les ont fait réfléchir
se sont fait critiquer par la grande
partie des républicains il faut voir ce
qu'il se passe lorsque métro mais où
d'autres républicains se dresse contre 2
montrant par exemple
encore de trafiquants beaucoup de
républicains se sont opposés à que mon
train de développer tous mais ils ont
été 1 mise au ban du parti
et des électeurs
se sont également détournés 2 et je
pense qu'aucun d'entre eux ne pourra
concourir à nouveau avec 38 c'est
vraiment extraordinaire de voir à quel
point le parti a changé au départ ils
ont collé contre 30 et maintenant donald
trump et le candidat principal des
républicains bénéficient d'une majorité
des soutiens et ses opposants eux sont
en marge du parti
il est temps que ça en 2024 c'est
évident la majorité des électeurs
républicains seront en sa faveur on a
pris ce soir qu'un homme s'affirmant de
l'idéologie arrêt de la suprématie
blanche a été arrêté avec une baïonnette
et une machette un près du siège du
parti démocrate à washington à quelques
jours d'une manifestation des partisans
de l'ancien président on va rester
prudent évidemment et pas tirer de
conclusions pour le moment on ignore
l'identité est vraiment de cet homme est
tout de même d'espère keane certains
fans de donald trump à ce qu'ils peuvent
être nuisibles à l'ancien président et à
vous-même en tant que partisan
donald trump ça nous inquiète
on ne
[Musique]
représente pas le danger
que prétendent les médias il ne
représente pas plus attachants que les
dingues du parti démocrate qui eux aussi
sont très peu mais qui sont sans doute
beaucoup plus que les fous parmi les
soutiens de donald trump
les dingues du côté démocrate ont mis le
feu à toutes les villes
des états unis en 2020 avec le soutien
des médias utilisés qu'il s'agissait de
manifestations pacifiques alors qu'on
voyait des flammes en arrière-plan des
images
terroriste
personnes vraiment dangereuses sont à
gauche ou plus longtemps et une personne
dangereuse au sein des soutiens de
bertrand puech a très peu
fait station revenir si à obtenir un
permis cinq candidats en 24 ans fois
qu'il annonce cette candidature ce qui
en fera bientôt je n'ai pas peur que les
soutiens de quatre hommes se montrent
dangereux j'ai peur que les villes
américaines il souhaite un santé par des
soutiens de l'an gauche lors de ce qu'on
appelle des manifestations pacifiques
donald trump on l'a entendu a qualifié
jo jo dan didio après leur très
chaotique des troupes américaines
d'afghanistan
il a reproché le timing du lion
septembre sur hayden est il le seul
responsable on se souvient il l'a dit
d'ailleurs lui-même que donald trump
avait négocié notamment cette date avec
les talibans ont février 2020
la première partie de cette question
la base
ariano kaboul était sécurisée elle
aurait dû être libre de centralisation
des départs
réduire ses coûts verte et toutes les
personnes qui souhaiteraient parties
auraient dû y être que buquen afin de
pouvoir partir à en sécurité
et au lieu de celà n'a utilisé comme
base aérienne dont un centre de kaboul
un kit entouré de milliers de personnes
qui pouvaient tout être des terroristes
donc les plans a dit que je partais à
l'encontre du bon sens
il n'a pas pris les bonnes décisions
pour la sécurité et le bon ordre
le départ de joe dalton d'afghanistan
effectivement à être fait de manière
odieuse et autres on a raison d'utiliser
ces mots puis l'accord
conclu par de la trompe avec des
conditions
les talibans devaient respecter un
certain nombre de conditions et si elle
respectera alors tenez petit tout
respecter cet accord
dire que je batte ont été contraints par
l'accord de donald trump par son accord
avec l'état roumain s'était fruits car
cet accord était déjà nous les non
avenue car les talibans avaient violé
leur terme et les camions on n'aurait
pas fait son loin si donald trump était
encore au pouvoir car il vous preniez
alors qu'il ne gagne pas je hayden je
redonne au monde lorsqu'il dit que
l'accord de l'entraîneur
le lou ye tout ce qu'a fait de jeu byden
c'était son propre choix merci beaucoup
d'effets perkins d'avoir été avec nous
en direct sur rt france ce soir